[Musique]
j'ai vraiment pas vu le temps passer à
temps mais tu étais où on n'a pas vu
depuis que tu es arrivé en bas tu sais
moi j'ai fait quelques ballades
j'ai été visités de trois châteaux j'ai
fait une ou deux vidéos un petit peu
d'accrobranche pour la forme et puis
j'ai vite et le mont-saint-michel aussi
c'était super sympa
ah ouais ça fait des bonnes journées
quand même moi je dirais pas que le
temps est passé si vite que ça
après c'est vrai que j'ai pas foutu
grand chose et je me suis pas mal
feuillage aussi globalement on a déjà
tous expérimenté le fait que le temps
que l'on ressent est un truc plutôt
variable en fonction de la situation
citées super heureux et qui vit un
moment de ouf et bien ça passe super
vite en revanche si tu es quand c'est
chez mamie sans internet
chaque minute te paraître une heure
voire 2 1 ce qui change pas c'est le
fait qu'on a tous en commun l'expérience
du temps qui fuit et que rien ne peut
arrêter
clairement on va tous mourir pourtant si
on pourrait penser qu'on ressent tous le
temps de la même façon et bien c'est
assez fou hein
chaque culture développe ses propres
nuances dans la manière dont il envisage
le temps qui passe est bien évidemment
non seulement les cultures influencent
la perception du temps mais le temps lui
même influence la perception du temps
pour être plus clair et sortir du
comique de répétition en gros on
n'envisageait pas le temps de la même
manière il ya dix siècles en plein coeur
du moyen-âge quoi
[Musique]
mais comment savoir comment on envisager
le temps au moyen-âge justement bas
c'est assez difficile mais à partir des
années 1970 1980 des historiens et des
sociologues comme norbert elias ont
commencé à s'intéresser à l'histoire des
mentalités et plus particulièrement à la
perception du temps et la première chose
qu'ils ont constaté 1 c'est qu'au
moyen-âge
en occident on ne veut pas passer à côté
du temps qu'impose la religion le
christianisme est en effet omniprésent
dans la société médiévale
il s'est fait une idée bien particulière
du temps c'est une vision linéaire et
non plus cycliques comme chez les grecs
anciens qui entièrement tourné vers la
fin des temps et oui dans les religions
messianique comme le christianisme et
bien il ya en effet un point de départ
et un point final dans les premiers
versets de la genèse dieu créa la terre
le ciel et le temps lui même à l'autre
bout de ce temps qui file tout droit il
y à l'apocalypse la fin des temps c'est
le grand game over finale de l'humanité
coin avec tree obligatoire entre ceux
destinés au paradis et ceux qui vont
directement en enfer sans passer par la
case départ mais vous allez me dire
attends de seconde les chrétiens ils se
sont quand même vachement inspirés des
anciennes religions pour monter leur
business là est ce que tu es sûr qu'il
n'ya pas un côté cyclique là dedans bah
vous avez raison d'insister 1
parce que si le temps chrétien n'est pas
cyclique il est finalement pas si
linéaire que ça non plus un adam et eve
sont expulsés du paradis on descend donc
du divin à l'humain puis jésus
un homme va racheter les péchés de
l'humanité là clairement on remonte de
l'humain vers le divin on n'est donc pas
dans un temps cyclique mais il y a de la
suite dans les idées quoi les deux
visions cohabitent donc et c'est pas
plus mal parce que le paysan moyens
clairement au jour le jour il vit
surtout dans une vision cycliques du
temps a dicté par la succession des
jours des saisons est globalement de la
vie agricole
mais concrètement comment ça se traduit
pour légende les bassins une question
super importante pour les historiens
parce que les derniers siècles du moyen
âge sont en fête au coeur d'un
basculement entre la perception
anciennes et une perception qu'on
pourrait dire un peu plus moderne pour
l'historien hervé martin en particulier
à la fin du moyen-âge verrait se
succéder trois étapes dans l'évolution
du rapport au temps juste
12e siècle dans un premier temps sur le
12e et le xiiie siècle dans un second
temps et enfin au 14e siècle
tout d'abord jusqu'au début du 12e
siècle l'otan aurait été perçu par les
sociétés médiévales comme fixé immobile
le temps et effets de cycle court fait
pour être répétée inlassablement
et oui les paysans le comprend assez
bien sont toujours attentifs aux cycles
de la nature avec laquelle ils doivent
composer pour travailler la terre
on a donc le rythme de la nature qui
s'impose naturellement à tout le monde
et à sa vient s'ajouter un temps imposé
celui de la religion par exemple avec
des fêtes chrétiennes mais aussi celui
du pouvoir avec le paiement de l'impôt
et éventuellement celui de la levée des
troupes l'aspect le plus important à
comprendre peut-être un c'est surtout
que la grande majorité des gens à cette
époque ville dans un flou
quasi-généralisée quand il s'agit du
temps la plupart des habitants des
campagnes ignorent leur âge exact
le jour du mois et même la mémoire des
événements qui peut pas se précise et
plus loin que à c'était il ya très
longtemps ou pendant le règne de tels
droits 1
c'est ce dont on se rend à ses comptes
en étudiant les dépositions de témoins
pour des affaires judiciaires au delà de
deux ou trois ans les dates deviennent
floues et beaucoup ont le plus grand mal
à estimer correctement les durées qui
les sépare des événements qu'ils ont
vécues au quotidien on exprime souvent
le temps via des oppositions ya par
exemple le temps de la guerre est le
temps de la paix
le temps du sacré et le temps du profane
en gros on définit le temps plutôt en
actions concrètes c'est un temps plus
qualitatif que quantitatif
par exemple si je demande un type vivant
au 12e siècle combien de temps il va
mettre pourra réparer ma botte tout
trouvé il va me répondre à bâle eu le
temps de faire brûler la chandelle en
entier ou encore à bas le temps d'aller
au village d'à côté un des seuls repères
temporels en zone rurale en fait c'est
la cloche de l'église qui va marquer
régulièrement le temps de la prière mais
aussi et c'est plus important
le temps plus exceptionnel si on fait un
événement particulier si un danger
menace c'est un personnage public et
décède
les cloches retentissent avec un rythme
différent avec une sonorité différente
et la population réagit en fonction de
ce traitement ce qui suppose au passage
que les ruraux au moyen-âge avait une
culture sonore assez répandu d'ailleurs
mais enfin malgré ça le temps chez le
péquenot moyens et ben c'est pas très
précis mais envoie l'idée c'est un temps
flottant mal mesuré les paysans du
moyen-âge sont donc en quelque sorte
prisonnier d'un temps qu'on fût sans
contours
alors ça ne veut pas forcément dire
qu'ils s'ennuient puisque par définition
un paysan médiévale ça travaille toute
la journée
mais finalement la seule perspective
d'avenir et de répéter les cycles déjà
vécu des jours et des moissons et vu
qu'on a cette notion de répétition on
comprend que c'était une société dans
laquelle le passé était d'actualité
puisque elle ressemblait quand même
vachement au présent ça se ressent par
exemple dans les textes de loi du
moyen-âge qui prétendent toujours
réaffirmée des lois ancestrales
considéré comme juste d'ailleurs à cette
époque même quand on produit une
innovation elle va prendre l'apparence
de la tradition plutôt logique puisqu'on
doit inlassablement reproduire les mêmes
actions sans espoir de changement autant
se convaincre que ça a toujours été
comme ça et que c'est la meilleure chose
qui soit alors c'est quoi la conséquence
de tout ça au moyen-age on a le plus
grand mal à imaginer le temps comme une
accumulation d'événements liés les uns
aux autres ça se voit très bien chez les
historiens de l'époque
leur récit qu'on appelle des chroniques
sont le plus souvent des séries de faits
décousu qui n'essaye pas de mettre en
évidence des causes ou des conséquences
contrairement à ce que pouvaient faire
les historiens romains au contraire dans
le mode de pensée médiévale les
événements n'ont qu'une seule cause la
volonté divine
du coup faire un lien précis entre des
événements et basse et plus forcément
une priorité puisque c'est dieu qui est
à l'origine de tout c'est un peu comme
quand tu as du mal avec un scénar d'un
film parce qu'il ya toujours un truc
improbable qui déboule pour sauver les
miches du héros et que ton pote qui est
un grand fan de l'oeuvre te sort un an
mais ta gueule c'est magique a
clairement on peut pas lutter 1
on pourrait ajouter un dernier élément
qui brouillent encore plus la perception
du temps au moyen-âge
vous allez me dire qu'ils sont pas aidés
1 mais chaque pays possède sa propre
chronologie car celle ci elle est
calquée sur le règne des souverains et
leur dynastie
ce sont donc les successions deux
générations qui vont marquer les étapes
du temps d'où l'importance de la
généalogie dans les sociétés médiévales
et comme je le disais au début de
l'épisode la perception du temps tel
qu'on cela représente ici c'est surtout
une perception qui est lié à l'occident
médiéval chrétiens les choses a été
probablement différente dans l'islam
médiéval et plus largement dans d'autres
espaces culturels et géographiques
comme l'afrique le japon la chine
l'amérique etc
voilà on a donc un bon aperçu du temps
pour le paysan du moyen-âge au 12e
siècle
c'est relativement floues et pourtant au
12e siècle et xiiie siècles on va voir
émerger un changement dans cette
perception du temps les historiens vont
constater qu apparaît une volonté de
précision de ce temps floués flottant
qu'on a décrit et ça se voit assez
timidement dans l'outillage avec la
diffusion progressive de l'horlogerie
mais aussi et surtout à travers le
vocabulaire qui emploient davantage de
termes pour parler du temps dans la
langue française le mot puisque devient
par exemple un moyen d'exprimer la
causalité et s'est passé cela puisque
ceux ci s'est produit avant mais ils
sont vraiment à deux doigts de remettre
en question la volonté divine 1 ou pas
et alors pourquoi on commence à remettre
en question cette perception du temps ou
plutôt cette approche du temps eh ben
c'est pas à cause d'un truc en
particulier à vrai dire c'est plutôt un
processus complexe qui a plusieurs
origines et qui s'étale dans le temps
mais on peut souligner le rôle du
développement de la bourgeoisie
marchande 1 par exemple ou celui de
l'administration de l'état
on va schématiser utiliser des mots qui
peuvent paraître anachronique mais en
gros les marchands doivent absolument
être attentif aux échéances de leur
contrat autant que vont durer les
trajets pour faire transiter les
marchandises les patrons doivent pouvoir
mesurer le temps de travail de leurs
employés
les administrateurs doivent fixer des
dates limites et des réunions pour
résumer on commence à ressentir le
besoin de synchroniser des actions
précisément pour être plus efficace et
gagner des thunes mais ça concerne
surtout la population urbaine et au
cours du xiiie siècle le temps reste
assez flou pour la majorité de la
population vivant à la campagne et
d'ailleurs manque de bol pour les
patrons le calendrier religieux dominent
toujours et le seul truc qu'il précise
bien en terme de temps c'est les jours
où on travaille pas
c'est mon épisode et tu m'as volé le
flap la bassir faisant du coup à la base
j'avais prévu de parler un peu de ces de
biologie et perception du temps de ce
que je pense qu'elle est très
intéressant à voir mais du coup personne
n'a voulu le faire donc j'imagine que tu
as bien d'être khadir donc cette façon
dans l'épisode on a dit qu'il y avait
des trucs aura proclamé oui ou non il ya
des trucs à dire bon ça fait toujours
plaisir de boucher les trous les soit
moi le premier truc qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est que on parle de temps en
linguistique genre il ya le passé le
présent le futur on conjugue etc et on a
l'impression que c'est tout à fait du
bon sens et que ce serait même quelque
chose d'universel
mais en fait pas du tout bas par exemple
le futur sans attaquer assez récent en
france est en tout cas et dans les
langues indo-européennes en tout cas le
futur n'existait pas en inde européen
c'est un temps qui est intéressant aussi
en allemand en anglais dans les langues
germaniques est donc une manière
évidente d'exprimer futur en fait dans
beaucoup de langues si tout simplement
d'utiliser le présent un temps où un
tank et non marquées et d'ailleurs on
l'a encore en france c'est quand tu dis
demain je vais à la plage
as-tu conjugue au présent et a même des
trucs un peu plus un peu plus what the
fuck c'est quand tu conjuguer à
l'imparfait pour faire un futur
tu peux le faire en français par exemple
deux jours plus tard il partait il
partait c'est un pet pourtant c'est de
l'avoir fait et ses 107 une action
passée voici un peu plus littéraire
c'est vrai mais n'empêche que on peut
utiliser un temps du passé pour exprimer
un futur donc ça c'est quand même assez
contre-intuitif si jamais on y regarde
il ya des temps aussi d'ailleurs qui
exprime l'absence de temps c'est à dire
qu'en grec il ya par exemple ce qu'on
appelle la orist la auris ça désigne une
action qui n'a vraiment ni début ni fin
c'est une action un peu dans sa
globalité
je vois par exemple si jamais je prends
la phrase la terre tourne autour du
soleil bien ses taux en français c'est
au présent mais en fait c'est aussi vrai
dans le futur ceci est vrai dans le
passé donc dans ce cas là la auris est
un temps qui serait vraiment tout
indiquée pour sa main d accord que
c'était pas vrai comment ça que la terre
tourne autour du soleil
tout le monde le sait que c'est faux
c'est une blague
c'est très drôle
nous arrivons donc à la troisième étape
de la révolution du temps au 14e siècle
on vit à ce moment là le développement
et la diffusion d'une invention qui va
révolutionner la mesure du temps les
horloges mécaniques connu des chinois
depuis plusieurs siècles
elle remplace peu à peu en europe les
sabliers et autres cadran solaire entre
le 13e et le 14e siècle dans les villes
et les villages il faut bien voir que
les horloges à l'époque un cd machines
qui sont colossales
elles mesurent plusieurs mètres de haut
parce qu'on ne sait pas encore
miniaturiser les mécanismes des tonnes
de métal et le savoir faire de nombreux
artisans sont nécessaires à la fin du
moyen-âge pour compter les heures avec
régularité maîtriser le temps est donc
un investissement pour les villes et les
villages mais tout le monde veut
s'équiper
on vous dire qu'être horloger à cette
époque c'est l'assurance de ne jamais
manquer de travail
en effet les horloges sont
complémentaires des cloches de l'église
puisqu'elle ne marque pas les heures de
prière mais le ton de travail
elles sont utilisées par les marchands
et les artisans en particulier les
drapiers qui ont beaucoup d'employés
pour déterminer le début et la fin d'une
journée de travail
et paradoxalement cette innovation qui a
permis aux bourgeois de s'affranchir en
partie de la mainmise de la religion sur
le temps bas vient des monastères plutôt
rigolo 1
en tout cas ce sont les confréries qui
ont développé des sortes de réveil qui
frappait les cloches pour réveiller les
dormeurs les moines qui étaient souvent
des artisans accompli ils ont ensuite
perfectionner ses mécanismes la demande
sociale elle va donc s'accentuer
rapidement dans les bourgs et les
horloges quitte les monastères ça permet
notamment de régulariser la duré des
heures parce qu'avant l'horloge on
utilisait souvent le cadran solaire et
le cadran solaire c'est pas le truc le
plus précis du monde s'il ya toujours le
même nombre d'heures sur un cadran
solaire
le problème c'est qu'il y a plus ou
moins de soleil en fonction de la
période de l'année une heure à cette
époque ça n'a donc pas la même durée en
été et en hiver puisque sur un cadran
solaire les heures sont très courtes en
hiver est très longue
en été et ça ça rend les journées de
travail très variable à la fin du
moyen-âge les ouvriers des ateliers se
plaignait donc souvent du retard avec
lequel leur patron annonçait la fin de
journée la mécanique des horloges va
régler le problème puisque les heurts
font désormais tout la même durée et
tout le monde peut siffler en
travaillant joyeusement on voit donc que
l'horloge mécanique fait basculer les
sociétés peu à peu vers une perception
du temps plus
crête est soumise aux calculs ce
décompte précis s'ajoutent autant vécu
par les paysans fait de rythmes naturels
et agricoles et va en modifier la
perception en l'espace de trois siècles
à la fin du moyen âge le temps va donc
glissé lentement mais sûrement des mains
de dieu vers les mains des humains
à partir du 15e siècle les rois et les
plus riches aristocrates commence à
posséder des horloges de chambre qui
sont une véritable marque de prestige
des villes s'y mettent aussi d'ailleurs
un comme à prague où la célèbre horloge
astronomique est construite en 1410 sur
l'hôtel de ville une horloge qui fait
encore aujourd'hui sa renommée et qui
d'après la légende vous à son créateur
d'avoir les yeux crevés afin qu'il ne
puisse reproduire son oeuvre ailleurs
toujours sympa hein de voir le
traitement des artisans l'époque au
xvième siècle leur usage se démocratise
un peu plus parmi les élites urbaines et
l'écart se creuse de plus en plus entre
les villes et les campagnes
pour ce qui est de la perception du
temps les historiens s'en rendre compte
une nouvelle fois un grâce aux
dépositions des témoins dans les
tribunes au xvième siècle les ruraux se
réfère plutôt à des catégories temporel
assez vague et souvent rapport avec des
actions concrètes
le temps de trajet par exemple tandis
que les urbains eux utilisent davantage
les catégories plus concrètes comme
l'heure et la date exacte
la suite de l'histoire vous la
connaissez c'est une diffusion toujours
plus grande de la mesure du temps et
avec elle d'une perception de plus en
plus précise du temps le temps ça n'est
plus des trajets ou des chandelles qui
brûle mais plutôt des heures des minutes
et des secondes le développement du
chemin de fer fera d'ailleurs beaucoup
évoluer le rapport au temps parce que
même si vous êtes paysans et que vous
voulez fier qu'à la course du soleil et
au rythme des saisons vous avez intérêt
à savoir l'heure qu'il est si vous ne
voulez pas rater votre train et puis
imaginez un peu si vous habitiez à tour
et que vous deviez aller à orléans avant
vous mettiez quatre jours pour faire 100
km avec l'arrivée du chemin de fer non
seulement la perception du territoire
est bouleversée mais la perception du
temps aussi le temps du voyage ne peut
plus être considérée comme une unité de
mesure fiable et le ressenti même du
temps doit être totalement bouleversée
ce que montre en tout cas cette
évolution dans le rapport au temps à la
fin du moyen-âge et bien c'est d'abord
que la technique et le mode de vie sont
intimement liés en l'absence d'horloge
mécanique impossible de se synchroniser
précisément les rendez vous se donne à
la louche un puisque les gens se
déplacent lentement et on ne sait pas
vraiment quelle heure il est au
moyen-âge à moins d'arriver le lendemain
personne ne peut vous accuser d'être en
retard ce qui est plutôt pratique va pas
se mentir avec l'apparition d'une mesure
exacte du temps puis des moyens de
transport rapide
il devient de plus en plus possible et
même du coup nécessaire de se
synchroniser l'horloge mécanique a créé
répondu en même temps un besoin de
précisions dans notre lecture du temps
aujourd'hui notre société pousse cette
logique à l'extrême les heures de nos
téléphones sont tout synchronisé à la
seconde près par l'intermédiaire
d'internet
le tout caler sur la moyenne de leurs
données par 500 horloges atomiques
répartis dans le monde entier
notre expérience du temps a donc été
définitivement homogénéiser pour
répondre à des impératifs de travail et
de communication et du coup on se
rapproche peut-être plus d'un tant que
l'on subit cette pression du temps qui
se rappelle à nous en permanence par des
sonneries des rendez-vous est toujours
plus de choses à faire ou à voir on
regretterait presque le temps flou 1 et
immobile du moyen âge un temps on était
obligé de prendre son temps
en tout cas si cette vidéo vous a paru
trop courtes ou même trop longue et bien
dites vous que c'est juste votre
perception du temps qui n'est pas la
bonne
en réalité j'ai vérifié elle est d'une
durée parfaite merci à tous d'avoir
suivi cet épisode n'hésitez pas à le
leak et commenter et partager comme
d'habitude et évidemment retrouver le
vortex sur dix corps dont vous pouvez
échanger sur tout un tas de thématiques
y compris celle là à la prochaine bombe
à les amis moi je me bats allez c'est
parti à temps mais quoi on n'a pas eu le
temps de profiter de toi bah ouais mais
bon fallait saisir votre chance qui le
jus 10 heures pour aller tu en profites
pas assez les uns des autres après on
regrette faut qu'on change ça ouais mais
tu vois avec ben le temps il passe vite
pas comme avec arno ou avec marie ou
avait que thibault
avec manon ou avec les a pas et florent
florence
[Musique]